First Grade,
Scifi cover artist was frank or Paul
discovered by the father of science
fiction publisher Hugo Gernsback.
In 1914,
Paul define the imagery that came to be
associated with Scifi tails is covers,
have amazing stories.
The first magazine devoted solely to
this new genre,
features,
spectacular spaceships and spacemen,
giant insects,
laser guns,
and a lot of really odd looking aliens
in those years.
The middle 19 twenties.
These covers were probably among the
strangest art that the average American
ever got to see on news stands,
these colorful garish nightmare visions
and leaped into the imaginations of
young readers.
Paul is such a towering figure in
science fiction because so many
influential writers and artists in the
field,
not to mention readers,
can trace their obsession with the genre
to the unforgettable experience of
seeing his covers for the first time.
The purpose of a book cover,
of course,
is to draw you in to peak your interest
enough to read the story behind it,
but on these covers,
paul launched a fascinating genre of
painting and design that rarely gets the
attention it deserves in the same way
that science fiction and fantasy as
genres historically didn't get the
attention that they deserved.
Interestingly,
one of the byproducts,
I think of this lack of attention was
that the cover art for these books got
to explore weirder and more avant garde
artistic styles than they would have
otherwise.
The revolution inside Fi covers came
with a revolution and book selling.
In 1939 Robert to graph launched pocket
books,
the first mass market publisher of
paperbacks in America,
and he was hugely successful and amazing
as it sounds.
No one really thought that people would
read paperbacks,
but when the pocket version of James
Hilton's last horizon sold two and a
half million copies,
people knew that there was a change in
the air as marked are noted in the daily
beast.
Suddenly the four point three by seven
inch format of mass market paperbacks
became the canvas for cover artists and
with more scifi selling and with the
genre getting more of it.
Stu,
culturally,
publishers look to artists who could
reflect the deep themes that the story's
explored.
Take Penguin the British bookseller in
the forties and fifties.
They were known for their classic orange
and white covers then in the sixties,
in an effort to raise the sophistication
of their science fiction offering.
Art Director Germano facility started
pairing novels with covers featuring the
work of popular modern artists.
For example,
James publishes a case of conscience
takes place on the planet with organic
almost biological shape.
Buildings for the cover for steady chose
a detail from data estin,
surrealist painter,
Max Ernst,
the eye of silence,
or Jg Ballard,
the drowned world of post apocalyptic
novel set in Oblique,
flooded uninhabitable London for this,
for Seti,
chose Eve 10 surreal landscape of
battered shapes and odd configurations
called the Palace of windowed rocks.
After for Seti,
a series of art directors through the
sixties and seventies commissioned
original works or did it themselves.
There was Allen Aldridge who created a
series of beautiful psychedelic images
over black in the late 19 sixties.
There was Franco Greg [inaudible],
who pioneered methods of experimental
photography resulting in a monochromatic
kaleidoscopic images in 1970.
Then there was David Pelham who made
this iconic cover for a clockwork orange
in 1972 and these gorgeous reprints of
the Ballard classics a few years later
over at ballantine books.
It was Richard powers who is really
pushing the limits of the form.
The ballantine's essentially gained
powers,
free reign to pull from all his
modernists and surrealist influences,
sometimes pulling completely away from
the actual content of the book.
The result was hundreds of covers that
could have easily filled gallery spaces
and modern art museums,
and while they were increasingly
abstract powers,
covers mind the subconscious in the
surreal,
in the same way that the best science
fiction does the present a world that's
warped often in radical ways as a
reaction to the world.
That is one of the things I love about
Scifi cover art is how accessible it is,
like literally accessible.
You can walk into any used bookstore
anywhere and get five of these old pulp
books for a dollar each.
I can own a vincent defeat and a Bob
Pepper and Ian Miller's insane cover for
Bradbury's long after midnight,
and then the art is with you.
It's in your home.
As you read the stories,
it's on your bedside table.
It's art you hold with your hands.
It's not precious.
It's been folded and creased and above
all,
it's weird.
Scifi and fantasy covers had the chance
to be weird,
not only because of the weird things
going on in the stories,
but because the genre was categorized as
pope and weird imagery sort of came with
the territory.
There are hundreds of artists and
thousands upon thousands of books in
this tradition.
I can't possibly cover it all here,
partly because a good amount of it is
forgotten.
Hiding away in crates at the back of
bookstores.
Next time you're at one,
pull some of those crates out and see if
you can't find a last chapter in this
eclectic and underappreciated sub genre
of art history.
Everybody,
thank you so much for watching and
indulging me in this passion I have for
Scifi book covers.
I've been wanting to do this video for a
while,
so I'm really,
really glad that I finally did it.
This episode was brought to you by VRV.
If you don't know,
Vrv is a service that pulls together a
lot of great content channels like
rooster teeth,
Mondo,
crunchy roll,
and funimation all into one place so you
can watch some of the best anime there,
but they've also added a lot of new
channels like movie which hosts a
rotating roster of 30 indie movies.
Something that I really love.
One other show that I personally like to
point out is the director's chair where
director Robert Rodriguez interview
interviews.
Other directors like Coppola,
George Miller,
Guillermo del Toro.
I'm also Gary and his demons is a really
funny enemy.
If you're into kind of like rick and
Morty and that style of humor,
you can only watch those shows with vrv
premium,
which gives you add free access to
everything,
all the channels and for a limited time
you can use the first link in the
description to get a 30 day free trial
of Vrv,
so definitely try that out.
Oh,
and they have offline mode now too,
so you can watch all that awesome stuff
on the go without an Internet connection
and that's pretty cool.
Thanks again guys.
I'll see you next time.